welcome to vlog daughters
folk of the flock well the diblock
Deborah Street so good it's really good
I'm gonna try this flavor yet shaping up
to be a pretty good day but today's not
really about me today is all about
supporting Julie and supporting Mathis
bye sweetie it's kind of a big day but
not because of anything that I'm doing
but because of Julie hey guys hey hey to
be shot anything yeah just a little bit
we just a judge right
yeah well use the red know what camera
is this Blackmagic pocket Cinema like
you're gonna be back here right even
going oh yeah of course along with the
drone how long do you want to do this
about 15 years yeah finally happening
take this I got it yeah look you're 10
minutes late we don't start running out
all right
now this is hockey game
you should play goalie today I love it
when she plays goalie you should really
get at it
all right your arms gonna go through
both of these up through there
the key goalie is not falling asleep if
I told you have the time the goals are
to score two just because the goalies
are ten I'm not paying attention to talk
to your team don't be afraid to scream
to clean your ear one of our team
leaders so by all meetings and scream at
those people the goal is that is the
captain of the team in most cases
so how did it end up well it went really
well
we had an amazing day and got a lot of
amazing stuff but I think we're gonna
need another David shooting really yeah
probably
and Leia did an amazing job your
producer no she's a director I think it
looks really beautiful I had all sorts
of stuff that I wanted to do today that
I wanted to accomplish that I sort of
needed to accomplish but if you're lucky
you have people in your life that you
get to show up for not necessarily that
you have to show up for but that you get
to show up for I get to take my kids to
school I get to pick them up from school
I get to take care of Julie and help her
out on her yoga video project today
which was super important to her and
something that she's been dreaming about
and planning for for a very long time
and that in and of itself is the gift
but gratitude is not my default setting
left of my own devices and if I'm not
taking care of myself I'm irritable
I'm discontent I'm prickly I can be
difficult to be around it's a practice
it's an action but when I am practicing
it when I am consciously taking actions
to connect with gratitude my life isn't
just better it's like way better and one
of the ways that I practice gratitude is
to enter into every interaction in my
life whether interpersonal or
professional with an attitude of service
not what can I get out of this but how
can I contribute and service is the path
outside the self it's the key that
unlocks the prison of the mind
and the truth is when you're in a place
of giving you will always always get
back tenfold so the question I want to
leave you guys with is what are you
grateful for and if you're like me and
you do have a difficulty or a challenge
in connecting with gratitude a great
practice that I rely on quite regularly
is to make a daily habit of creating a
gratitude list when you wake up in the
morning it doesn't have to be the first
thing in the morning but it's best if
you do it soon after you wake up to get
out a notepad a pen and paper don't do
it on your computer and write down a
list maybe the top five or the top ten
things that you are grateful for it's
such a simple thing it should only take
you like two or three minutes to
accomplish but if you do it and you do
it consistently it will change your life
and that is a promise